une réserve de sioux cerné par
l'urbanisation le bas de belleville
meurt mais ne se rend pas trois hectares
quatre pâtés de maisons 1200 logements
3000 habitants selon devait disparaître
pour faire place nette à une zac un
projet de la mairie de paris
contrarié fin 91 par le tribunal
administratif
trois ans plus tard un projet nouveau
est arrivé avec cette fois 80% de
réhabilitation la victoire d'une
association qui reste vigilante
le programme de construction c'est deux
tiers de logements hlm un tiers de
logements ce qu'on appelle intermédiaire
c'est-à-dire pour des gens qui gagnent
jusqu'à 40000 francs par an donc c'est
pas du tout de logement social ça c'est
pas pour les gens du quartier
mais le deux tiers de logements dits hlm
je veux dire s'avère même trop cher pour
les gens qui vivent actuellement dans le
quartier donc il faut construire ce
qu'on appelle du logement très social
ce qu'on appelle le ps à insertion éclat
et la ville a prévu seulement que trente
logements comme ça dans le dans le
projet d'aménagement
alors qu'il ya 180 familles à reloger
pour les occupants du 23 rue ramponeau
le problème ne se pose même pas 25
artistes soit ici l'un des endroits les
plus charmants du quartier un lieu
présenté par la mairie est condamnée au
bulldozer
c'est un vieux con fait vivre c'est un
lieu qui est important pour le quartier
parce qu'il ya les familles qui viennent
y voir les gens même les éducateurs les
éducateurs de rue qui travaille avec les
enfants du quartier ont vu les les
progrès et le plaisir qu'avec les
enfants à venir ici déjà ne serait-ce
que de venir dans le passage de
travailler au milieu de vrais artistes
pour eux c'est une grande aventure une
aventure désormais entre les mains du
conseil de paris des élus jusqu alors
peu sensibilisés par le sort de ce petit
village
viol est tendu vers l'un des petit derby
de la capitale